i've got the best job in the world in
the best city region uh
in the world and i'm just so grateful to
all of those
people who went out and put their trust
in me it means a lot it's quite humbling
actually
sophie to be honest it's a brilliant
result i'm so
so uh grateful uh to everybody and
we are on with something here you know
we are actually leveling up this country
we are building the new greater
manchester
uh and from here we are going to do some
radical changes to our transport system
the
great manchester public have given me a
big mandate to bring our buses back
under public control
for the first time in 35 years and i'll
be getting on with that job come monday
morning
get you on with the job on the buses
best job in the world but you'll forgive
me for
laboring the point a little bit um can
you rule out
running for the leadership of the labour
party
i've been elected as mayor of greater
manchester as i say that is where my
focus
is i left westminster politics i'm not
an mp you have to be an
mp uh to stand uh for the leader of the
labour party and i'm not aware that the
rules have changed so no
my focus is is here uh sophie and you
know
in the distant future you know if the
party were ever to
kind of feel that it needed me well you
know i'm here and they should
they should get in touch but no i'm i'm
here and i want to support labour
nationally by saying look look at what's
happening here
where there is devolution where there is
strong
authentic connected representation
people
are buying into it and the council
results here reflect
that so the labour party has been
lukewarm about devolution up to this
point
and it needs to change very
significantly and get right behind it
and rebuild
from the bottom up and that will be my
advice to the leader but also to the
whole of the party
if in the distant future labour needs
you they should get in touch
sounds a little bit like you're leaving
the door slightly ajar
well i i say i've you know i have tried
twice to be the leader
and it's never worked so i i know you
know i'm not
um under any illusions if you like that
you know it's never worked for me in the
past i feel i'm in the as i say the best
the best job in the world and we've got
a massive job ahead of us but i'm i'm
here to help
the labour party uh if if they need it
but they need to change let's be really
clear about this you know it can't be
just sort of cosmetic changes that come
out of this there has to be substantial
change in the way the labour party is is
working they have lost
an emotional connection with parts of
the country that you know is going to
take a lot of work to get back so
i think the party has to do a lot of
soul searching about
these results and understand why we've
done well in places like wales places
like greater manchester
and it really needs to then you know buy
into
english devolution and build from the
bottom up that's what these results are
telling them
i'm really interested in your uh
diagnosis for labor
going forward because there have been
these spotlights of
of light for labour you of course
winning in the first round increasing
your vote share
in greater manchester in wales as you
mentioned too
at labour managing to get that effective
working majority really in the um
in the welsh parliament and yet doing so
devastatingly
badly in other areas of england
what do you think labour needs to do now
to change
well i think if you look at those
results and you try and understand them
the pattern is where there is devolution
a strong locally driven
uh operation people are buying into it
more so here
liverpool city region you've just heard
from um
uh west of england where they're buying
into it now and they've elected a labour
mayor
wales there was a reward for the labour
party there
where they haven't got it in the same
way in parts of the north east
well there's a greater sense of
alienation uh there
from from the party so that's the lesson
i would i would say you know there is no
route uh to a general election victory
that is not
done through building from the ground
upwards
uh winning back um the trust of people
that's been lost and changing
fundamentally
the way we go about things i've said it
many times labor is too london centric
and it's still the case and i
i don't know how many times i have to
say it to them until they change but now
they must change
it's interesting you're saying there
about the london-centric nurse of the
labour party it was quite similar
diagnosis from culliva mood who said a
london-based bourgeoisie with the
support of brigades of woke social media
warriors has effectively captured the
party
do you agree with that assessment
i'd not show up quite [ __ ] in those uh
terms but
it's why i left you know in the end i
just didn't
feel as though it was my world and i
could do
what i wanted to do i never thought i
could be truly myself
uh in westminster politics but i think
people do see the real me in this in
this job and i feel
uh invigorated by it i'm passionate
about it you know who wouldn't be
being the mayor of a city region like
the place that i'm talking to you from
now it's
an amazing place you know with just
brilliant people it's got so much
potential it's been held back actually
by westminster and that angers me i i
feel it's westminster that's caused the
north south divide and it annoys me that
we always have a debate about politics
in the this country
westminster is the only show it's
actually the problem
it's the problem when you say
westminster do you include labour in
that diagnosis
yeah the whole of it yeah the way the
whole thing works and of course
of course i do um it just doesn't work
for for people in the way that a more
devolved approach really does
work and connects with people and you
can see that in these
in these results so yeah i'm i believe
we are building
something really important and i think
sophie to be honest with you
this is one of the most significant
elections
uh in british social history uh
certainly in the post-war period because
the
the public are saying they want more
devolution
they do not want the old way of doing
politics
all conducted through westminster they
are calling
for something very different and we are
doing something very different
here in greater manchester we we involve
people from a range of communities in
the policies
that we make it's just a better way of
doing things
and and i think this the results of this
election are saying that loud and clear
to every one of the westminster parties
you may remember last year when i had a
little disagreement
with the prime minister well i i i stood
up for the people here
and this is the point we've had
devolution so far that's been a bit sort
of baby steps
and you know the first time where there
was a disagreement
westminster when i answered back to them
said oh well we're not having any more
devolution that
that i think the public are saying
that's wrong we want more of it
and this is something that i think now
the prime minister is going to have to
have to take on board and he's going to
have to define what leveling up
is we're going to get on with building a
new public transport system here from
from monday and here's my test to the
prime minister catching a bus in harper
hay
here in greater manchester should cost
the same as it does in harringay
in london but currently it's one pound
55 in haringey
it's over four pounds here and until we
have
fairness in terms of the cost of public
transport this country won't be leveled
up it simply cannot be right
that the poorest parts of this country
have the most expensive public transport
just finally uh while i've got you you
know you're talking about the london
centricness of westminster
you're talking about these results being
a wake-up call saying that labour needs
to change
hand on heart do you think kierstalmer
gets him
yes i do i actually do he was here last
week and we had an honest conversation
about
about all of these things change is
needed uh and i do think
he understands that to be fair to care
of all of the five leaders that i've
worked
under he has done more to respect local
government
and also to call for devolution but it
needs to become real now
we need to see proper change not not
cosmetic change
and we need to see labour really coming
out and putting forward a very ambitious
uh uh program because i think the
conservatives have been rewarded in
in the tease valley uh there's no
getting away from it uh
good devolution used properly gets
better results for the party in in local
uh elections and in the parliamentary
election in hartley pool so
that's the big the big lesson you know
from my point of view i often feel
invisible to the labour party at times
you talk about them
we were talking about them ringing me up
before i get no vote in the election of
a leader
as a mayor i get no uh platform at labor
conference
i've got no rights within the the
standing orders of the party because
they haven't taken it seriously
and and this is a big wake-up call for
them and they need to to hear it
okay andy burnham thank you uh very much
for coming on the program i have to say
i'm not sure
totally shut down those questions about
leadership good to
talk as always